foreign
I've wasted decades trying to do what I
thought was expected of me how do I let
go of this perfect idea of who I'm
supposed to be
I think this goes back to the intense
perfectionist where there's some sort of
crystalline endpoint
I just want to be happy is often once
they can be a nebulous endpoint I want
to be happy I want to be satisfied I
want to be free I want to be fulfilled
yeah or it can be specific in the sense
that I want a million dollars a million
followers a million pats on the back
whatever it might be
we think that we want happiness a
Perpetual Bliss but not realizing that
when you get that it's actually Mania
it's not what we're seeking we think we
are seeking the things that we aren't
even seeking and so when I look at
Ricky's question here
hey I've wasted decades trying to do
what I thought was expected of me how do
I let go of the perfect idea of
this is who I'm supposed to be yeah
and I feel like Ricky is speaking on
behalf of humankind because we've all
done that and we'll all continue to do
that in ways that sneak up on us and
he's in a really or she is in a really
powerful position right now because what
they're recognizing is that I am
behaving that's called behavioral
perfectionism in the way that I think
I'm supposed to and it goes back to the
how and why guiding questions about
whether you're perfectionism health is
healthy and the why to his question is
that so that I can be accepted by
whomever is expecting these things right
whether it's Society or their parents or
their partner or whatever and how am I
doing it I'm doing it in a way that
makes me miserable that is making me
feel like I am a one-dimensional person
and that I am not fully alive and so I
would you know just be able to take a
moment and say thank God God energy the
universe however you want your highest
self the language is irrelevant that you
are aware of this now you are in a place
of power where you're starting to
understand oh I deserve Joy now not an
excellent plan to be very happy later
like in being able to have language
around that and say that is what
self-worth is and I have self-worth If
he if he or she or they did not have
self-worth there would be no frustration
so the feeling of frustration and
disappointment in self and I would say
despair because that sounds like a long
history is really just coming up to
inform
the person that they are ready for a new
way of living yeah it sounds like their
self-worth comes from how other people
think of them
so if they're constantly trying to live
up to other people's expectations they
are a essentially looking for approval
with a certain group or certain person
whatever it is
um living up to other people's
expectations like putting other people's
expectations before your own yeah is
like this perfect recipe for discontent
I feel like yeah and I know it sounds
kind of selfish because what I'm saying
is like hey your expectations come first
and live up to those and then if you
want to take on other people's
expectations great like that's okay to
do that but if you're not living up to
what you expect of yourself like that is
there's always it's always going to feel
like a mess inside completely and I
think another great way to reframe that
is you cannot show up for other people
for your community for your kids for you
know your friends when you are living in
that way because it's not even you that
the person is getting it's just like
actor tryouts it's like the you where
it's like Emma um do you like this now
and we're not actually we don't feel
safe around people who aren't themselves
we feel unsure we can't quite get a
temperature emotional temperature on
them you're not fully present you can't
be fully present and trying to
control impression management and so
when we're around people who aren't
fully present we kind of back away a
little bit and when you're around
someone who's present and who is
allowing themselves to be their whole
full self it's like intoxicating like
I've never met anybody like you because
you haven't because if you let yourself
really be yourself instead of worrying
about
the proverbial like likes and not likes
you're going to get on every comment and
and career choice and your home decor
whatever then you know people I think
are so drawn to that because it awakens
them to the presence inside themselves
and because you feel alive you give
other people more license to feel alive
and more permission to do things the way
that they want to do them like some
people are not here to be on the same
kind of path of Consciousness as you are
so some people will for their whole
lives live and die expecting you to be
the kind of son that does this or the
kind of partner that does that and
they're never going to change and you're
always going to disappoint them because
you're never going to do it the right
way because it's not ever going to feel
like you and something's always going to
feel missing and the thing that's
missing is your full presence right so
yeah I'm just gonna say like so when you
don't accept yourself then you look for
external validation to be accepted but
what I hear you saying is like until you
accept yourself you could get all the
external validation that you want but
it's Gotta It's gotta come from you
first I mean I can only imagine if I
gave you the power Catherine to make me
feel worthy or not yeah it's like oh
does Catherine like me does she accept
me and I'm like tweeting her oh she
responded to my tweet oh yeah I'm worthy
I'm worthy yeah but then you always need
more of that as well yes and but but
giving someone else that power is um
what makes you powerless
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free